[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt und herzlich willkommen in meinem
garten
dieses jahr hatten wir ein richtig
schönes gartenfest beim christian in
mauer im lebensraum müller und dort
haben wirklich ganz viele tolle menschen
kennengelernt unter anderem auch die
astrid und den jörg die beiden die
züchten nämlich apfelbäume und zwar
nicht nur ganz herkömmliche apfelbäume
und ich hab das ja schon mal erzählt
weltweit gibt es über 2000 apfelsorten
viele davon kennen wir schon gar nicht
mehr denn im supermarkt werden einfach
nur noch etwa 13 14 apple angeboten und
zwar sucht sich der supermarkt oder auch
natürlich die apfelbauern suchen sich
die sorten aus die ertragreich sind die
robust sind die nicht schädlings
anfällig sind die immer schön perfekt
rund aussehen saftig aussehen und die
dem kunden einfach am besten schmecken
was ich ziemlich schade findet denn
viele alte sorten gehen natürlich auch
verloren und ich finde so ein bisschen
auch die geschichte des apfels auf
unserem sommerfest haben astrid und jörg
mir erzählt dass der neue apfelsorten
haben und die apfelsorte ist richtig
besonders das ist sie und zwar ist sie
von außen rot und innen wenn man rein
weist ist sie auch roth fleischig das
heißt dieser apfel ist wirklich auch der
perfekte snack apfel für kinder sieht
hübsch aus er schmeckt lecker es saftig
aber man kann ihn natürlich auch weiter
verarbeiten und hat so zum beispiel rosa
apfelmus oder einen rosa kuchen einen
rosa apfelsaft und das ganze komplett
ohne künstliche lebensmittelfarben
genial oder ich zeige euch mal die
beiden zeige ich noch den christian und
dann erzähle ich euch noch was zum apfel
denn diese apfelsorte die werden wir
heute taufen das wird unsere eigene
apfel unser apfelbaum jetzt immer noch
die einzige mit diesem regen aus stütze
das hat voll in strömen geregnet
ja denn christian kinder ja christian
hat er bei uns hier den garten gemacht
und das hat eine frucht menge die
wirklich sehr hervorragend wachsen bei
uns wäre schon ziemlich viel geerntet
dieses jahr und konnten nicht mal alles
selber essen also
alles schön auch verteilt aus verfolgt
ja na ja und beim christian sommer wie
gesagt jahres kennengelernt und ihr
zweite tafel beugen ja wir produzieren
die wir stellen die her sehr viele
verschiedene sorten unter anderem auch
genau und die beiden die kamen auf dem
gartenfest auf uns zu und hat es da guck
mal werden in ganz tolle apfel also
eigentlich muss ich da jetzt mal kurz
rein weißen ich muss den zeigen
es tut mir leid ich bin ich für euch ist
guckt mal richtig lecker und ich glaube
nicht nur mir sondern auch vielen
kindern wird dieser apfel gut schmecken
und vor allem wird er glaube ich auch
schon durch die farbe überzeugen
genau wie schöne ist ja dass die dann
beim saft und kuchen den chips und
apfelmus rosa apfelmus wer kann da schon
nein sagen
wir werden diesen apfelbaumes taufen
wirklich eine große ehre dass ich dem
apfelbaum den namen geben darf und ich
meine wir haben bei uns im garten und
katzen apfelbaum pflanzen jetzt schon
gut für die umwelt
genau das war ja immer auch euer
anliegen habe mir gerade die seite hier
ganz stark für die insekten für die
bienen
gepflanzt und da leistet natürlich so
ein apfelbaum auch einen großen anteil
ist ein toller polen spender
gerade im frühjahr wenn er wenn er blüht
also es gibt deutlich mehr vorteile wie
dass ich den apfel handeln kann
kann man da ungefähr sagen was so ein
apfelbaum für die umwelt tut also es
gibt studien darüber was ein großer baum
macht er ist jetzt so ein bisschen
kleiner aber der wird dann ungefähr
sauerstoff liefern für bis zu zehn
menschen
und dann windet er natürlich co2 das ist
ja wichtiges thema und verdunstet dann
ungefähr 100 liter bis zu 100 liter
wasser am tag das ist dann auch dann
wird die luft kühler und feuchter
spendet schatten die wurzeln halten die
erde fest alle über so viel gute
möglichkeit für uns jetzt als komplette
garten anfänger wenn ich jetzt noch nie
was im garten angepflanzt habe was muss
ich bei einem apfelbaum beachten kann
ich da was falsch machen oder trägt er
auf jeden fall nächstes jahr also der
wird auf jeden fall als versprechen kann
man das nicht zu 100 prozent aber noch
genau also ich würde sagen der kriegt
nächstes jahr nach der taufe kann man
diesen apfelbaum dann bei der bestellen
als frucht gänge und bei der verpackung
haben uns auch ganz viele gedanken
gemacht das heißt dieser baum weder
komplett ohne plastik geliefert und
versendet das heißt co2 neutral auch
also da das ist dass der korb trotz der
topf der topf 4 ist auch die eierschalen
das material ist praktisch wieder
erfahrung heißt verrottet komplett
könnte theoretisch sogar mit ins
pflanzloch gehen wenn man das möchte
oder aber abziehen und auf dem kompost
das ist auf keinen fall als als abfall
zu sehen sondern als organischer masse
die wieder in den kreislauf gehen kann
aber auch das ganze bildmaterial welches
etikett es ist kein gramm kunststoff
hier an dem baum so dass das eben auch
unser beitrag zum klimaschutz
und auch wenn wir versenden das heißt
wenn er über einen shop bestellt wird
das enden wir co2 neutral ist im karton
es ist kein kunststoff heiliges
klebeband dran etc also wirklich 0%
plastik und das soll unser beitrag sein
perfekt ich sage zu euch immer geht
nicht ford kaufte vor ort natürlich gibt
es den baum regional beim christian
direkt oder eben weniger von woanders
herkommt dann lohnt es sich nicht
hinzufahren nur wegen diesem buch
natürlich lohnt sich weil bei euch
gibt's wieder sehen aber es werden
natürlich nicht co2 neutral nur wegen
einem baum da hinzufahren
also können auch ganz einfach online
bestellen und wie gesagt alles co2
neutral ohne plastik ohne müll und das
finde ich schon wichtig wenn man etwas
nachhaltiges handeln
ihr habt euch überlegt dass wir mit
dieser apfelsorte die wir jetzt heute
taufen meiner stiftung unterstützen
das heißt von diesem baum geht immer ein
euro an meine stiftung finde ich echt
wunderschön vor allem weil dann einfach
die kinder was davon haben und wenn ich
noch was dazu sagen darf also meine
eltern die kennen sich natürlich sehr
gut aus im garten aber für mich war das
alles obwohl ich im garten aufgewachsen
wie ein bisschen neuland alles selbst zu
besorgen selbst anpflanzen und ich habe
echt immer gedacht dass bäume einfach
total teuer sind im einkauf sind sie
aber gar nicht und ich muss sagen dieser
baum ist ein jahr alt da wird dann so
als einjähriger warum verkauft und er
kostet nur knapp 30 euro
also ich denke mir dann immer so krass
da wird ein jahr gepflegt und wächst und
gedeiht ihr kümmert euch darum und dann
kostete einfach mit 30 euro kommt bei
euch in den garten und dann habt ihr
einfach ein ganzes leben lang was davon
und vor allem ganz wieder tolle apps
also ich finde ich schon wahnsinn was
gärtner leisten
das habe ich dem team der umfrage
gemacht und jeder irgendwie war total
beeindruckt und dachte kraft richtig
haben und vor allem verfehlen
naturereignisse die dann noch so darauf
einwirken man hat ja echt nicht oft
einfluss drauf in köln jahres gleich und
kein jahr ist gleich ja also ich würde
sagen wir pflanzen jetzt den baum ein
und dann gibt es später noch die absolut
auf das machen wir kommen dahin am
besten dafür den anderen obstbäumen
[Musik]
wir nehmen den topf lag damit dass sich
die wurzeln schneller entfalten können
sagte papa kommt schon mit dem
wasserschlauch dann können wir hier
wenn wir jedes mal heben wird anfangs
geheißen dass die sitzungen nach außen
stehen möchte um so schneller warte man
mir reden gleich sein papa ist ein
schlauch tätig
lectra weiteren beiratsmitglieder
moderation konsum gibt sagen perfekt
papa sehr gut
also wir reißen uns einfach hier immer
so auf damit die wurzeln nach außen
stehen und dadurch eben die bilanz sind
noch schneller im erdreich fest wurzeln
und worauf sie achten müssen
bis hierhin ist es ein wilder apfel und
habe hier ist es im prinzip eine
apfelsorte und diese stelle muss immer
aus dem erdreich rausschauen das heißt
wir platzen nur so tief wie der baum im
topf das passt ganz gut dann erfüllen
sie außen vor
mit dem lockeren material
[Musik]
dann für dich also verdichten wir die
erde
[Musik]
und hier ist ein gis rand des da kann
man einfach dann auch mal wenn es
erforderlich ist den schlauch hinlegen
eine weile aufgedreht lassen ganz leicht
ins wasser läuft nicht davon sondern
geht zu 100 prozent an den baum
das haben wir uns von apfelbaum hier in
unserem garten und wir haben dann kurz
überlegt im prinzip nur wie der
apfelbaum heißen soll und ich habe mir
gedacht wir machen das einfach nach
meinen beiden töchtern ella und samira
und mache ein wortspiel draus mira und
elmar heißt im türkischen apfel das
heißt wir haben auch gleichzeitig sein
schlagzeugspiel echt schön und elvira
ausnahme den gab es noch nicht und jetzt
machen wir einen schöne gegen kopf also
es gibt nur ein kleines problem und zwar
der apfelbaum ist er wirklich neu und
ihr seid das schon dabei ihn zu züchten
aber wie viele gibt es denn jetzt davon
rufen wird 100 er ist nur limitiert und
ein apfelbaum kann man mittlerweile im
prinzip das ganze jahr pflanzen aber am
besten ist doch im herbst den preis der
boden noch warm vom sommer aber auch
schon nass genug vom herbst das heißt am
besten jetzt um die jahreszeit aber bis
zum frühjahr hin dass er gar kein
problem
und nächstes jahr gibt es dann
hoffentlich mehr bäume aber jetzt
erstmal ganz limitiert auf 100 das heißt
die könnt ihr dann gerne beim christian
einfach bestellen bei den vorgängern und
jetzt würde ich sagen machen wir die
abläufe genau das heißt man tut gutes
für sich mit einem gesunden apfel gutes
wird die umwelt und auch noch gutes für
meine stiftung
echt eine tolle aktion ich würde sagen
wir mal ist die apfel taufe er trommelte
steam zusammen und ich war ganz kurzen
apfelkuchen also wissen ich hab mir
überlegt ich mache da einen ganz
einfachen apfelkuchen beim apfelkuchen
ist wirklich das einfach das beste
deswegen gibt es jetzt einen quark öl
teig dann kommt da die äpfel drauf und
dann noch als topping die streusel für
den quark öl teig verwende ich 150 gramm
quark 1 300 gramm mehl drei teelöffel
backpulver 75 gramm zucker eine prise
salz etwas tonka wonka 40 gramm
sonnenblumenöl und 100 gramm milch dann
kommen da die äpfel drauf und weil wir
jetzt einfach die in mira apple zu
schade sind denn wir haben nicht so
viele packe ich jetzt einfach mit ganz
normalen äpfeln dann nehme ich jetzt
etwas säuerlich sorte wetter gleich noch
zitronensaft dazugeben und dann gibt es
da auch die streusel dazu dafür verwende
ich dann 200 gramm mehrere 100 gramm
zucker eine prise salz etwas vanille
extrakt und 100 gramm butter und da
gibt's jetzt auch keine bestimmte
reihenfolge
ich nehme jetzt einfach zuerst die
trockenen zutaten also dass mehrere mit
dem backpulver prise salz und zucker
die färöer ist kurz miteinander so
verteilt sich das backpulver schon mal
richtig schön und dann kommen da die
flüssigen zutaten dazu also dass der
quark da könnt ihr gerne auch joghurt
benutzen oder crème fraiche oder schmand
zum beispiel ist in tonga
das öl und die milch und jetzt einfach
ganz kurz alle zutaten verrühren
[Musik]
das war schon mal der erste part der
teig ist fertig und kommt jetzt hier
direkt in meinen back rain wenn er merkt
dass er so wie hier nur ein bisschen
fest ist dann gebt einfach noch ein
bisschen milch dazu ich würde jetzt auch
noch ein bisschen milch und würde ich so
einen kleinen schluck da können jetzt
einfach sein dass es ein bisschen zu
klein war
also macht dann noch mal so zwei drei
esslöffel milch dazu
[Musik]
so ist es perfekt und quark öl teig hat
er den vorteil dass man ihnen entweder
kneten kann also mit etwas weniger milch
oder ebenso verrühren kann wäre es mehr
mint kneten würde ich ihnen jetzt wenn
ich zum beispiel ein blechkuchen mache
aber hier möchte ich jetzt erst in ruhe
kuchen charakter deswegen ist jetzt ein
bisschen flüssiger doch besser und jetzt
hier direkt in die backform einfüllen
zum kuchen geht auch echt super schnell
vor allem kann da nichts gewinnen wie
bei rührteig zum beispiel da kann nicht
passieren dass man aus versehen die
butter mit den eiern gerinnen lässt von
daher mache ich denn echt super gerne
vor allem wenn es mal schnell gehen muss
ein bisschen verteilen
dann stehe ich dann kurz zur seite und
kann die streusel verrühren dann nehme
ich jetzt einfach die gleiche schlüssel
kennt auch zuerst die streusel machen
und die kurz kühl stellen dass sogar oft
besser und für die streusel gebe ich
jetzt zuerst das mehl das salz und den
zucker in die schüssel und da kommt
jetzt nur noch die butter mit dazu und
etwas vanille extrakt und dann könnt ihr
die streusel entweder mit den händen
verkneten oder einfach ganz kurz mit dem
handrührgerät mit den knethaken
[Musik]
[Applaus]
guck mal die aspekte haben wir auch
diesen apfel mit gegeben erinnert mich
so ein bisschen an schneewittchens apfel
weil das archivgut ist wird
wahrscheinlich im supermarkt nie
angeboten werden weil er einfach nicht
perfekt rund ist aber ich finde diesen
apfel wunderschön nicht nur von außen
sondern auch von innen guck mal so sieht
er aus tatsächlich ohne lebensmittel
farbe eingefärbt kein photoshop keine
farbkorrektur und der ist wirklich
richtig schön saftig knackig und vor
allem leicht säuerlich also auch echt
lecker den benutze ich jetzt noch hier
für den apfelkuchen und diese art film
hat auch noch keinen namen das heißt auf
diesem apfel den namen geben schreibt
einfach eure vorschläge hierunter das
video und der vorschlag der dann
genommen wird der gewinner erhält dann
einen apfelbaum
da habt ihr euren eigenen apfelbaum mit
eurem namen als auch das gewinnspiel
startet jetzt und jörg tauss tritt die
suchen sich dann den namen aus und ich
verkünde dann denke ich glaube das ist
eine richtig coole aktion so recht sagen
dass bei äpfeln aus dem supermarkt oder
vom wochenmarkt das tut es mir irgendwie
nicht so wie die schale abzustellen weil
ich mir so denkt okay da bin ich selber
gezüchtet ich meinem auf mache ich dann
noch so ein traum aber bei apple aus dem
garten die kann ich einfach nicht fehlen
weil die sind halt so besonders und da
gibt es eben nur eine begrenzte anzahl
von einem garten deswegen lasse ich die
jetzt ja auch drin
vor allem hat eine richtig schöne farbe
und die apfelschorle
das ist wir alle unter der schale sitzen
die meisten nährstoffe
das haben wir immer gesagt
[Musik]
meine beine ab
da sieht es lustig aus es sind darin
fünf stellen lücken da wie in einem haus
in jedem stückchen wohnen 2 keine chance
und fein die linke drin und träumen vom
schönen bäumen ein
meist geht es so ich weiß nicht aber es
passt jetzt mit bisschen zitronensaft
vermischen
mein gott gibt der abwehr schöne farbe
richtig toll und die kommen jetzt hier
direkt auf den teig die streusel darüber
und dann darf der apfelkuchen schon im
backofen und ich gehe gleich wieder nach
draußen dann machen wir die apfel taufe
[Musik]
eigentlich viel zu schade diese äpfel
abzudecken
aber ich liebe einfach apfelkuchen mit
kreuz und die abwicklung mit oder ohne
streife
[Musik]
guck mal das ist saft vom elmira apfel
deswegen ist der rosa und da ist jetzt
unser apfelkuchen und jetzt machen wir
eine absolut auf übrigens wäre ein apfel
chips macht also äpfel dirt dann sehen
sie so aus als hätten die coole
geschichte ist ja auch ein apfelbaum zu
schenken
wenn dann die person jedes jahr nein
denn das besondere ja jetzt schon zu mir
auch ein apfelbaum werden nein deswegen
kriegst du keine angst dass er mich
denkst und deswegen bin ich ja gut als
war es hinter euch alle gerne ein glas
weg ja wir holen noch am besten macht
man gerne kochen und das ist ein
flugzeug ohne alkohol
aber das hier papa zusammen
ja ist quadratisch der sturz von april
an
ach so dankwardt jedoch mit dem sport
hat dann gehen wir alle zum apfelbaum
ein apfelbaum
nein es ist nicht deine abverkauf der
apfelbaum gehört jede maus und wie
als wir uns heute hier alle versammelt
um diese apfelsorte in mehr zu kaufen
ja und jetzt erst mal hinten trinken
apfelsaft wert aus wie eine russische
oligarch also 1000 dich auf den namen
elvira schmid perfekt auch wenn wir auf
das projekt
vielen dank dass ihr die stiftung
unterstützt also wie gesagt geht immer
ein euro vom baum andere stiftungen
direkt und dadurch mal was gutes für sie
denn man hat einen leckeren apfel hat
etwas gutes für die umwelt weil man den
baum pflanzt und man tut etwas gutes für
die stiftung
genau das heißt also jeder gewinnt bei
den linken und unterstützte ist für
unterstützen natürlich auch martin
luther gesagt wenn ich wüsste dass
morgen die welt untergehen würde würde
ich alles noch ein beschluss wird und
macht gerne beim gewinnspiel mit und
sucht euch einen namen auch für die
nächste apfelsorte und juni ist
ausgeschlossen
und nur sagen juni für ein apfelbaum ist
komplett ausgeschlossen
guten appetit und bis zum nächsten mal
werde gebraucht die kleine dicke
kürbisse einer murat nehme oder so wir
sind ein team wir hatten ja eigentlich
zur auch durch meinen block 1 und 2 t
shirt übrigens ein abfluss sehr gesund
ja und nein willst du länger ich selber
auch kirchlich ja und ob er sich nämlich
hatte angeschafftes zu lang dem was sie
meint
[Musik]